l'horreur absolue deux exemples la
Bosnie
aujourd'hui quand il y a eu la guerre
civile de Bosnie vous en souvenez on a
été obligé de faire appel aux
Américains pour mettre fin aux exactions
des
Serbes et l'Union européenne est
intervenue après coup pour reconstruire
tout ce qui avait été détruit notamment
les bâtiments publics notamment les
bâtiments scolaires et nous avons mis
comme condition
élémentaire à au fin de cette
reconstruction que désormais les enfants
des trois communautés qui s'étaient fait
la guerre qui é d'ailleurs des
communautés religieus c'est pas des
communautés ethniques différents
ethniquement c'est c'est les mêm les
mêmes populations mais pour des raisons
historiques des religions différentes
c'est les enfantsoté
seraient scolarisés dans les mêmes
locaux et donc si vous allez aujourd'hui
à saralevo à banialoua vous vérifierez
qu'en
effet tous les enfants sont dans les
mêmes locaux sauf que au rez-de-chaussée
vous avez par exemple les petits
musulmans au premier étage les petits
orthodoxes au deième étage les petits
catholiques et que chacun arrive à
l'école avec dans son cartable un manuel
d'histoire dans lequel on lui apprend
que ses parents auraient été tué par les
parents duudessus ou par les parents du
dessous et l'autre exemple qui va
peut-être surprendre davantage et
scandaliser encore plus c'est l'Irlande
du Nord
autant en Irlande du Sud l'enseignement
de l'histoire est remarquable et
complètement apaisé autant en Irlande du
Nord vous allez à Bast ou à
London vous constaterez que non
seulement il y a encore plus de murs et
de fil de fer barbelé qu'avant l'accord
qui avait mis fin à cette guerre civile
quiael les troubles du du Good Friday du
vendredi sa
98 mais les petits catholiques vont
toujours aux écoles catholiques les
petits protestants vont toujours à
l'école protestante et ils apprennent
que leurs parents ont été tués par les
parents de l'école voisine ce qui veut
dire qu'il y a en Europe des pays ou des
régions dans aujourd'hui en 2024
où l'enseignement de l'histoire sert à
entretenir à feu doux les haine
nationale qui ne demanderont le moment
venu enfin c'est la crainte car partir à
feu vive